hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the NCTC 3000 project mapping
the genetic codes of 3000 pathogenic
bacteria presented by Julie Russell head
of culture collections at national
infection services in public health
England
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of laborat and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation just click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter Julie Russell I will now turn
the presentation over to her Julie
thank you very much for that
introduction and I can confirm that I
have no disclosures to make so the
learning objectives for this
presentation are really for you to
understand the value of culture
collections in biomedical science
I'd like people to recognize the
significance of historical trends in
understanding microbial evolution and
recognize some of the benefits of long
reads sequencing techniques for
delivering reference genomes for
pathogenic bacteria and finally I'd like
to be able to identify how the wider
scientific community can contribute to
the biological resources of the future
they're preventing human infections from
occurring is one of the key targets of
the organization where I work which is
public health England or pH II the
organization's mission is to detect and
improve public health and respond to
public health emergencies we also
protect the nation from public health
hazard things like poisons and chemicals
and radiation bioterrorism and we
prepare for public health emergencies so
public health England for example have a
significant role in preparing for the
London Olympics in 2012 now public
health England is the latest incarnation
of an organization that existed in
varying forms within the United Kingdom
since 1950 during the Second World War
there was a lot of fears about
biological warfare and that prompted the
government to set up the emergency
public health laboratory service and
that provided support to doctors and
medical offices and identifying
bacterial strains Britain's health care
system pre 1948 really didn't work very
well and this change with our National
Health Service Act in 1946 and is
through this act the Public Health
Laboratory service was performing
established and a PHMSA's role is to
provide microbiological investigations
of communicable disease outbreaks and
drinking water and food products but of
course delivering of Public Health
objectives of preventing infections
becoming ever more pressing that the
global instances of antimicrobial
resistance in in bacteria and viruses
and fungi and parasites is increasing of
course is a really serious problem
anyone who goes to microbiology
conferences the world over will be aware
that this is always discussed the
problem of antimicrobial resistance but
in order to combat infectious disease
mounting microbial resistance we really
do need to know more about the organisms
that cause disease about the virulence
mechanisms which is how they how they
actually cause the disease and how
they're transmitted and finally the
evolution of antimicrobial resistance
cell my next slide I've got two quotes
that I selected from experts within the
UK and the first one is from Dane Valley
Davis and I selected this quote because
James Valley is specifically
highlighting the antimicrobial
resistance could take us back to the
19th century into 19th century medicine
that's a period that I need to go back
to in order to tell you the story of our
NCTC 3000 project but what I want to say
is in the nineteenth century that was at
a time of hope because our understanding
of the causes the spread and the
treatment and prevention of infectious
diseases with improving but now it's
kind of more period of trepidation
because actually we're not quite sure
what's going to happen we don't
necessarily know that things are going
to get better
and the second quote seismic indeed
comes from Jeremy Farrar who's the
director of the Wellcome Trust and he's
raised something I think is also very
important in the impact of antimicrobial
resistance you've got some seem to be
that we can't for example treat
infections such as your infections or
pneumonia or bacterial meningitis but
actually what it also means is that
today's routine procedures things like
caesarean section transplants and joint
replacements and counter treatments
these went any longer be safe procedures
these could actually become
life-threatening
hatice's so
we go back to the 19th century and think
about what was going on then it was the
dawn of health improvements and I'm sure
many know the story of in 1854 John Snow
was one of the fathers record eulogy and
he refused to accept that cholera was
airborne or this miasma theory and he
famously plotted the cholera cases in
London on a map and then by doing that
she identified the source of an outbreak
of a particular water pump and he had
the pump handle removed and the cases of
cholera immediately began to diminish
this is really because people were
starting to get to grips with
understanding the transmission of
infection although snows germ theory of
disease wasn't widely accepted until the
1860s and it wasn't actually until the
1880s that Robert Cox successfully
isolated the cholera Vibrio this was the
age of some really great scientists in
addition to Robert Koch I've just
mentioned in Germany that was also Louis
Pasteur in France and in the u.s. we had
salman Waxman and and baby Henry Bergh
II the famous Augsburg use manual and
the you came was a little bit behind
some of those countries when it came to
microbiology but in 1888 apparently as a
result of a meeting between between cork
and Pasteur and Joseph Lister a new
Institute was set up in London and this
will see Lister Institute of preventive
medicine and this institute was
established in Chelsea in central London
with the donation from the Guinness
family and he had two primary aims
fundamental scientific research into the
causes prevention and treatment of
disease in man and animals and secondly
to prepare and supplies protective and
curative materials now of course there
were no antibiotics at the turn of the
20th century but the Institute did
develop vaccines an antitoxin is ranked
internationally up there with the
Pasteur Institute of course the
Rockefeller Institute in New York
there's also very forward-thinking
microbiologist at the Minister Institute
and that was dr. John leading him and he
recognized the need for trustworthy
source of globally available authentic
bacteria for scientific studies and this
is a need that's still very pressing
today and with that fall he went on to
establish the National collection of
pipe culture in nineteen to
so national connections type cultures or
NCTC was the very first collection in
the world established with the specific
intention of providing or fencing
microbial cultures so microbiologists in
other laboratory to users research so
the word of the culture collections
established but not with this particular
aim to provide cultures for others and
although they named it the national
collection NCTC always had a global
reach and although the name indicates a
collection of type cultures which are
also called type streams and those are
the strains on which the description of
a species is based all the strains in
NCTC ants actually type cultures and
just as a side note all bacterial
species have a type strain it's not
necessarily the most typical example of
the species in fact some type strains
can actually be really quite atypical so
initially MCTC included bacteria fungi
viruses plasmids all of which were
considered to be for scientific
importance however our NCT was
established other national collections
followed in other countries and they
also collaborated and share their
strains such as 80cc in the US but in
1947 li and CPC curator which has Manuel
Collins decided that he was going to do
something different because he decided
the NCTC would only include bacteria and
it would be only those bacteria that
were of significance either clinically
or secondarily you wanted to focus on
quality over quantity all the strains
that fell outside is really different
stitute some in the UK and they went on
to form the nucleus of several other
specialist national collections such as
the national collection of plant
pathogens the national collection of
industrial and marine bacteria in
Aberdeen in Scotland and the national
collection of pathogenic fungi which
continues to sit within public health
England so some Karen really wanted to
ensure the authenticity every culture in
Moni new MCTC anything that didn't meet
these high standards was discarded
he was absolutely determined to show
that it was possible to distribute
cultures that were authentic that were
pure that were typical and the fact that
this is now broadly accepted is normal
practice
for any culture collection anywhere in
the world and I've noticed I'm visited
many of these collections I think this
is a measure of his success
they're only freeze like cultures from
quality control check batches were
issued to third parties I freeze-drying
policy which introduced later on was
really very similar to the same
procedure that's used today there's Sam
Cowan and indeed the whole of NCTC
transferred from the litigants titute to
the public health of our tree service in
1950 and specifically transfers to the
Central Public Health Laboratory which
is based in Collinsville in North London
and actually NCTC is still housed in
Colin belt in the same area it's not
actually the same building the building
that we have now with actually opens in
1985 however it was important that a lot
of the strains that are included in NCPC
came from some really really well
regarded and deposited scientists at the
time so include people like Robert [ __ ]
Alexander Fleming Florey and chain
Waxman who was responsible for the
development of streptomycin and indeed
other sciences such as Marshall and
Warren who in the 1980s with people who
responsible for identifying that and
Helicobacter pylori was in fact the
causative agent of peptic ulcers
in all my previous slides there was
something from there some Alexander
Fleming that was a letter that was sent
by Alexander Fleming about the Oxford
staff the octave staff is an organism
that was selected by the Oxford group
which were group of scientists working
Oxford University and this is the strain
that they used because they wanted to
test penicillin and they've recognized
the value of being able to test
penicillin the world over using the same
strain and that is why they deposited
this strain which we've NCTC the basic
five seven one and it's become known as
the octave staff and it's actually one
of the most commonly used organisms form
NCTC even today so one of the reasons
that the NCTC was moved because because
it was very close to the reference
laboratories and the reference
laboratory the work people weren't
laboratory such as NHS laboratory send
strange that they need identifying and
it is an example of a more recent
situation but have been concerned since
2011 about the emergence of plasmid
mediated collision-resistant in animals
and in humans this was first noted in
china now we've got of concern around
the world and in the UK we have an
antimicrobial resistance and
healthcare-associated infection
laboratory and that has affected its own
strain too excited to have a look using
whole genome sequencing to see whether
in the strains that it already collected
would carry this plasmid this MCR one
mechanism for collecting resistance when
they look through the strains they
actually identify one strain of e.coli
that did carry the NCR 1g this has been
isolated from the UK hospitalized
patients in 2013 what they did was they
deposited this train with NCTC very
quickly with NCTC
one three eight four six and is e-coli
was also in addition to being able to
NCTC was listed as a control strain for
the european and you cast which is
antimicrobial susceptibility and it's
now used as a control strain regularly
in hospitals and anyone who's testing
antimicrobial susceptibility now
diseases still have the detention to
demonstrate populations and NCTC stores
outbreak strains attend don't come back
to the turn or fee of the 19th of the
18th century so we go back to the
borough war and we have here some
strains of typhoid due to outbreak of
typhoid fever in South Africa in 1900 so
one of the first games to be included in
the collection is actually NCTC 160
ounces 160 of strains to be included in
the collection we can get back to the
very first stain of all in the
collection which have NCTC worn as its
catalog number that was isolated from a
british soldier who died of dysentery
during World War one and then we've also
got a strain 20:28 the maps from the
type of outbreak that always spread fear
and fascination it's an outbreak of
plague have happened in 1920s in what's
now known as Indonesia asked if we move
on to more recent outbreaks NCTC have an
authentic strain of Legionella
pneumophila
that's a strain that caused the release
allot break of an ammonia type of
illness in u.s. Legionnaires disease
attending a conference in Philadelphia
in 1976 and that's known as NCTC
one more more 92 and only a few years
ago in 2011 entities obtained a strain
the cause the second largest outbreak on
record of foodborne illness attributed
to Ishida toxin-producing e.coli which
is serotype O 104 now this infected
mostly people in Germany and they also
caused deaths and serious illness in
people further afield as well and this
was associated with contaminated bean
sprouts I've talked a bit about MCTC and
the cultures that we have there the
bacteria chemical and veterinary
importance I just like to note that that
is only one of four collections operated
by public health England the other three
all established of course after 1920
after NCTC and those include the
National collection of pathogenic fungi
that respected in 1947 after Sam Cowan
has decided to change the focus of MCTC
and then we roll forward to the 1980s we
have the European collection of
authenticated cell cultures so that
started up and really preserves and
distribute
cell cultures of human and animal origin
and finally we have the smallest in the
newest of the collections although it's
still nearly twenty years old and that's
the national collection pathogenic
viruses that was established in 1999 now
all four of these collections volved
under different management the different
management philosophies they were
challenging for some staff when in 2003
all these collections were brought
together under the same management
structure and those collections if I'm
actually responsible for now personally
I think it made a lot of sense to bring
them all together because actually all
the collections have the same remit in
the end and that's to provide authentic
cultures so the global biomedical
community in order to improve quality of
research and diagnostic testing so why
do we need authentic cultures well when
scientists devise research projects or
develop diagnostic tests they always
think really hard about the procedures
they want to validate the equipment
they're going to think about which
reagents they want to which tips to fit
the purpose and the data analysis
they'll be thinking about whether they
have the right software they're doing
the right statistical test but when it
comes to biological resources sometimes
they seem to think it's okay after all
that worked use it all cultures and back
of someone's fries I'm not going to do
the job and I suppose sometimes it might
do but sometimes it won't through the
read a grave risk associated with that
so if you think about it if you think
microorganisms are susceptible to
picture antibiotic and you know what
your control strain is you'll get more
likely to get the right results and if
you're using something that you're not
sure about your authenticity if you get
an incorrect result when you're testing
an antimicrobial susceptibility in a
clinical lab you can actually give the
wrong treatment for patients you
actually have an impact on someone's
life so really having the also tick
control is far better idea and if you're
researching breast cancer it's good to
know that using breast cancer cells
you're not accidentally using and
survival cancer cells for example
hero cells which are very commonly
misidentified cell lines because we all
know a lack of reproducibility in
scientific research is a major concern
some mystery in reproducibility have
been attributed to
misidentified
culture so perhaps it might be useful to
just give a little bit of information
about how a culture collection operates
when all the culture collections
operates in a similar manner not only
before within phe but pretty much all
the others as well and what happens is
the collection receives the strains and
the data from the depositor for person
who's spending the culture and the data
really is very important as well and
then once you receive the strains we'll
culture them make sure that they're
viable that they're alive that they're
pure is are not contaminated and we
check the identity and then we use the
appropriate preservation method to
prepare in parallel a master bank which
will be kept indefinitely and also the
first batch was lock and supply and when
the first stock grows low we go back to
the master bank to make next one so what
we're doing here is avoiding the serial
subculture and the master bank in every
subsequent batches quality control test
is to make sure that you survive the
preservation process which is setting
freeze drying or lyophilization for NCTC
cultures and then we need to test the
authenticity and those tests can be
morphological and we make sure that the
organism looks right we're also going to
make sure the phenotypic test the
biochemistry tests are okay and we'll do
some genomic testing as well and if the
depositor has identified a particular
specialist test that we may not be
familiar with within our own
organization we would send examples from
the batch back to the depositor to ask
them to also confirm that what we have
in the collection what is preserved is
exactly what they sent to us in the
first place so again there's
authenticity test undertaken by the
depositor then NCTC was his first batch
has all been prepared and it passed its
quality control tests what we then need
to do is enter all the data into our
data management system and that would
include not only the location sustain
but also the stock control but all the
biosecurity information safety
information the limitations of supply so
sometimes the positives might want to be
polled every time we spot providers
frames they deposited and we can
accommodate that
that's what they need am i doing that we
need to put back into the interview
stock control system so all that
everything related to that particular
Strayed is all in the same place and it
may be the depositors are concerns about
commercial use and if they want to know
about that between faculty instruction
for that as well once all that has been
completed and the strain has been added
we then have to put it on the online
catalog and that means it's been made
available to third parties and to give
an indication of that we probably
accession around 300 new NCTC bacterial
strains every year and then we
distribute around 10,000 NCTC ample to
third parties now I mentioned that the
data is really important the metadata
associated with the culture that really
adds value they want to know when we
receive the cultures ideally the dates
and the source and the site of infection
we don't always have all that
information but of course we can out to
it in the same way that the collection
itself is dynamic and we receive new
cultures all the time and occasional
cultures die we have to remove them with
the data we can add data and which makes
them more valuable and that might be
that we add face to because we've
retrieved additional information by
mining or kind of documentation or we
review publications but it may be that
was generated new data for some of the
historical strains and that is really
what I'm going to focus on next this is
generation of new data I'm going to
start talking about the murid collection
so in addition to the thousands of
strains that we have listed in the
online and CPC catalog we also hold
other donated collections and these are
stored spatially but not most publicly
available because of lack of resources
so any pieces actually receive any
public funding so we have to generate
the income from the sales of the strains
to deliver all the operational costs so
resources a bit limited one of these
collections that we stored safely but
not been able to make available this
murray collection consists of several
hundred strains dominantly intra
bacterial see and these were a mask by
Professor Everest George done Murray in
Canada
and he's got practicing during the
pre-antibiotic years but was between
1917 in the early 1950s and his son who
was also microbiologist robert murray
inherited these strains arranged to have
the murray collection transfers can
occur for it from canister 20 pieces in
the 1980s and with the help of and NCPC
scientists we sort of grow his picture
there so with actually a Canadian
national strains of both the UK small
number of ampuls of freeze-dried
cultures of each strain were prepared
and they were put into storage but they
were neglected although they whether
they're put away safely we have two
scientists in NCPC in the API ohmic data
and the Q and they studied these strange
demonstrating the common occurrence of
plasmid groups known to carry
antimicrobial resistance what I really
wanted to do was determine whether
pre-antibiotic era plasmids belonged in
the same groups as the modern with this
new classes and why modern I'm talking
about in the 1980s and it appeared that
medically important bacteria acquired
resistance over the past 25 years ramune
version of new genes into existing
classes rather than by the spread of
previously rare classes so this data was
really valuable this was all new data
that's already enhancing the value of
the Murray collection however in 2011 as
these things often are the result of a
Charles conversation in a pub between
MCTC scientists and dr. Nick Thompson
from the welcome penguin statute that
led to a discussion about Murray
collection the Murray collection is a
collaborative piece from that discussion
in the pub became a collaborative
project to sequence the genomes of the
bacteria in the Murray collection and
that work was undertaken by Kate Baker
at the Sanger Institute and Hannah
MacGregor in NCPC and the subsequent
publications really very interesting
with the whole genome sequences to this
additional 500 strains and also as a
result of this we did make the Murray
collection available as a link at the
bottom of that slide that really takes
you to to the publications associated
with that piece of work and another
example was related to NCTC one which
I've mentioned before the very first
strain in the collection
group of bacterial strains to be
deposited with empty piece in the
Shigella species
Shigella is associated with dysentery
these ones were articulated from
soldiers who died of dysentery or
suffered from dysentery in France during
the First World War
now these are British soldiers but in
fact dysentery was very common across
all the troops I think in the First
World War but we do know a little bit
more about the first strain we used to
and this is due to a really fantastic
piece of work that was done by dr.
Allison baver together working with Kate
Baker in the Thompson all of people
worked at the Wellcome Trust Sanger
Institute at the time and this strain
was listed in our archives as a cable
strain and our and Allison baver who had
particular interest in military history
one of the cable actually beam soldiers
name bearing in mind the deposit was
known to work in military hospitals in
World War one and after a huge amount of
research what made the determines was
the strain was actually isolated from
private earners table and he died of his
infection in 1915 and she found these
memorial stone which can be found in the
wimmer of Cemetery in France very close
to the side to where the military
hospital has long died so this provided
additional data about the screen and
that's very interesting but it's not
necessary a huge scientific significance
however bake croissants and sequence the
gene expensive.if Shigella textile we
compared it the whole genome sequence
more recent Isis fish together flexing
right couple of things that were really
useful interesting when we did this
first of all they determined a plasmid
that was likely to have carried some
virulence genes in MCTC one was probably
missing and they reckon this could
possibly be due to serial pathology with
the strain of it is necessary because as
I said we try very much in NCCC to avoid
serial subculture but free is trying to
preserve the bacteria was only
introduced by Samuel Town in the 1940s
those strains that were brought into
MCTC in 1920 needed to be subculture to
keep them alive and possible during this
period we lost one of the plasmids from
NCPC war but nevertheless they're
absolutely delighted that they generated
a high quality sequence of the bacterium
chromosome and having a one in a 100
year old genomes compare monster
again really provide some clues about
the recent evolution of Shigella one of
the things they noticed is the NCTC one
is resistant to penicillin and that's
perhaps not that surprising because we
think about this and these strains
probably exposed to soil and you get
lots of fun uniform so they could easily
have been exposed to naturally arising
penicillin but how does the group also
found that modern Shigella flexed
nourish strains have evolved greater
resistance to quite a number of other
antibiotics for the cable strain was
perfectly capable of fending off and
again there's a couple of publications
there in The Lancet which can be found
through the link on the bottom slide
there so we move on to the NCTC 3000
project because it follows on directly
from the work of the Murray collections
also incorporated by MCTC one work we
were delighted to be contacted by
professor Julian partial who had the
passage in genomics team at the Sanger
Institute and he contacted us because he
wanted to propose something far more
ambitious and one's work we've done
already he wanted to generate whole
genome sequences for three thousand and
CTC bacteria I can't really remember why
we chose three thousand it represented
about half of the publicly available
collection and the only thing we did
agree on that it would include all the
pipe streams but all of those would be
sequenced if we were able to take this
project forward so we applied for and
we're actually granted funding from the
Wellcome Trust which covered not all but
some of the cost of the project and our
initial intention of actually to shortly
technology to learn the genomes and an
important aspect of this project and the
point of view of the Wellcome Trust was
that we make this genomic data widely
and freely available as soon as possible
the project would require
NCTC to select the bacterial strains to
extract the DNA make sure it was
inactivated and that required quite a
few validation studies or you need to
make sure that whatever we're going to
send to the finder is absolutely safe
and then we'll be done all that we're
going to transfer the DNA extracts to
the Sanger Institute and then Julian's
team would be responsible for the actual
sequencing for the annotation for
uploading data onto the public databases
and then finally in
ll NCTC could develop what we call the
e-resource this is essentially an
enhanced searchable website that would
ensure that all the metadata is easily
available easy accessible to third
parties shortly after we started this
project there was a really very exciting
development when Julien Parkhill
contacted us and tell us that PacBio
wanted to support the project and I'm
not a molecular scientist but I can tell
Julian was really excited about this and
very soon understood exactly why because
what this meant was we could generate
better quality closed complete genomes
this meant this longleaf technology
could be applied to the very ripe wide
range of organisms in the collection so
some of the other ways of sequencing
would have some sort of limitations such
as related to G / C ratios of the
organisms perhaps but regardless of
those organisms we're going to sequence
it's this technique that probably work
really well and give us close genomes
and so for example we have strains with
a lot of repeat sequences such as
clinical importance species like
Bordetella pertussis but we felt these
that probably be able to be sequence
successfully there was one challenge in
adopting this longleaf technology and
that was that we really needed to ensure
the quality of the DNA extracted from
strains were suitable so we needed to
avoid over sharing the DNA because this
process would require high quality high
molecular weight genomic DNA although it
was a bit of a challenging certainly
surmountable
because there are a lot of advantages as
I've already mentioned and some of the
advantages uses PacBio sequencing works
but not only with the process deliver
many more closed genomes it has mapped
repetitive genome but it could also
access methylation patterns this is
important because we know that lots all
the bacterial genes are active all the
time and all being expressed and DNA
methylation is one of several methods
are thought to be involved in the
expression of genes associated with
virulence and of course because our
collections that pathogenic organisms
differences is very significant so this
process is also sensitive it has a
relatively short run time and using
sticks or images to really demonstrate
its really simple to look at the
those and see that on the left hand side
you've got a jigsaw with hundreds or
thousands of pieces which is essentially
short lead sequencing and it would take
quite a long time lot of accuracy to get
a complete picture whereas on the other
side you've got this small four or five
piece pixels which is basically what
long reads sequencing is and it makes it
a lot easier to put those few pieces
together and get very accurate picture
so now we've got some NCTC 3000
statistics and I think they really speak
for themselves the first thing that was
really exciting is the team actually
over delivered because rather than three
thousand strains we extracted DNA from
three thousand two hundred and thirty
the reason we did that is because it's a
high-throughput project so we couldn't
just stock if something went wrong we
needed to keep delivering the DNA and we
needed to have related to allow for
anything going wrong so if there was any
mix-ups and we have to discard a batch
even though we have a lot of to see in
place we're aware that with something
that such a high throughput the scope
for human error and we also needed to if
we suspected something had been over
sheared or our colleagues of the Sanger
told us that we'd over Shearer then we
could just press on and move on to the
next next batches of DNA so that was all
pretty exciting but these stats as well
the fact that we actually managed to
sequence
eight hundred and fifty two species we
represented eighty two families and the
sequencing that began in November 2013
was finally completed in June 2018 and
excitingly more than half of these of
the organisms that we sequenced the
manage to assemble the genome in a
single contig like one piece 92%
assembled in less than five context and
nearly a quarter of them had evidence of
plastic so that was important because we
knew we talked about losing classrooms
before we also had a concern that
perhaps long reads sequencing would look
we wouldn't be tech some of the plasmids
now it's possible we haven't detected
some of the very small task needs and
I'm going to go back and look at that
later but it's evidence that clearly
picking up plasmas through these
sequences
and that's another way of looking at the
data night might appear here that and
these are the strains that we sequence
for entry back to curiosity are kind of
disproportionately represented actually
that is really focus on the collection
itself the collection and is really
focused on health outbreaks also these
are caused by salmonella by Shigella
biting Caroline hospital acquired
infections include organisms such as
entra bacterium Klebsiella and and these
are the sort of organisms that is good
in the remix of Phe so it's not very
surprising these statistics
to 852 species and ht2 families I think
is a pretty broad spectrum and you can
see these pathogens as well then we have
clearly contributed a lot of genomes to
some pathogens concerned what my serial
gonorrhea there we've got emotions
influenza Shigella dysentery a whole
range of pathogens when we completed
this we're in a position to announce
that we've completed this project
there's lots of the assembled genomes
needs to be uploaded and final stage of
releasing won't happen till next year
with regards the e resource but the main
part of the project have been delivered
and the world really quite a significant
global press interest in project and
perhaps unsurprisingly the headlines
really focused on the dangerous and the
deadly the bacteria that were preserved
in the collection of caused diseases
like plague and dysentery and cholera
and there was also a lot to talk about
decoding superbugs and there was a lot
of focus on tuberculosis and super
gonorrhea which obviously captures the
imagination in the press although to be
fair I suppose we think about it like a
bacterium tuberculosis and Neisseria
gonorrhea between will infect nearly 90
million people a year with 1.7 million
deaths attributed to tuberculosis in
2016 and recent w-h-o reports state that
gonorrhea is becoming almost untreatable
so perhaps that does explain why there
was so much attention but I think some
of the headlines really important the
headlines are also about what we
contributed scientifically that
obviously is dangerous in the deadly
important but my colleague dr. Sarah
Alexander trolled the databases in may
28 team found that some of these really
quite astonishing data so 12% of type
strains that we've sequenced not only
have no whole genome sequence data
available for the slide strain but
actually there was no base for available
for the entire species
thirty percent of the pipe strains have
no previous whole genome sequence paper
at all and for forty four percent only
draft genome data was available so this
really was feeling very important gap in
the public databases for important
pathogenic sequences
the key lymphocytes are really important
we can resolve recombinant to repeat
regions we are able to look for
virulence determinants from the genome
sequences for drug and vaccine
development we can determine a safe
target site and the file jet phylogeny
and population genetics can also be can
be undertaken using this data all I'm
going to do now is just give a couple of
examples of where the data community tc3
elephant project is already being used
i'm first example is from cat halts
group in Melbourne Australia I might use
the genome sequence from 81 strains
Klebsiella species so plenty Allen
ammonia is associated with antimicrobial
resistance and healthcare-associated
infection and there are multiple
mechanisms antimicrobial resistance
within this species and the species
consists of capsular organisms and these
can be distinguished
phenotypically according to the capsule
type but the genetic diversity
associated with capsular type is largely
unknown so the group looked at genomes
from 2,600 strains Klebsiella including
those 81 from the MCTC 3000 project and
from that data they managed to identify
134 distinct capsular low file kalos by
not only that they also presented a new
tool for the identification to kalo site
from genome sequencing the cop is not
only used for tertiary mamani i but it
can also be used for other species where
capsular epidemiology is thought to be
important and then a second study this
one looks at M Clostridium perfringens
posted in proof engines is an organism
that causes human and animal infections
and this case the author sought to
understand and characterize the genomic
variation and the pan John and the pan
genomic diversity and they used five
strings from NCTC 3000 and to add to a
further 51 strains of their own pushes
in print and strains they really wanted
to understand the virulence factors
associated with C perfringens and the
genetic relatedness astray
what they found that the pan genome is
really quite diverse some frequent gene
exchange in evolutionary history
associated with profile ashes the toxins
and antimicrobial resistance genes and
that potentially influence pathogenicity
so this is a quite different example of
where the NCTC 3000 data with being used
but we have lots of future challenges
despite the fact of being used one of
those is really to get people to
understand that within scientific
community that all sensing biological
resources are essential we need to
persuade colleagues that they should
take time to deposit strains and that
will benefit science we know the source
of myths out there people keep asking is
how much it costs and politics trains
with NCPC but in fact it created
applauses naturally all staff are there
and they can help either with transport
with compliance with by security
regulations focus and cost anything at
all means then packaging that what
people need and it's clear that
sometimes people are concerns about why
should we give the strains to you and
you going to make a lot of money
commercially which sadly isn't the case
at all but we actually only provide
strains for research and diagnostic
purposes and any commercial requests are
dealt with separately we can discuss
that with the depositors that's what's
required I think it's also important to
consider that actually really with whole
genome sequencing based technologies we
may end up with less cultivation of
microorganisms and if you have less
cultivation of microorganisms we won't
be able to add to these collections in
the future
because constellations I can CTC cannot
easily be updated retrospectively they
need to be updated in real-time because
they represent some living history or
human infectious diseases
now of course even when people say they
are using authentic strains that's not
always a case and just got a couple of
examples here where we can see that
scientists have been sharing the strange
probably with the best will in the world
but we really like to say be very
careful about about sharing strains they
may not be what you think we are and
trade have names and shamed a couple of
people here so please don't be those
scientists that send out strains to
third parties without also educating
them so in summary I hope I've convinced
you of the key role that culture
collections play such as NCPC in
biomedical research and in diagnostic
testing historically strains helped us
with our and for a historical strains
help our understanding of microbial
evolution and today's circulating strain
remember tomorrow's historical strains
so it is really important I think it's
important to note this if you need
reference genomes long gene long Reed
methods are more informative about the
PacBio technology that we used in our
NCTC 3000 project was fantastic and we
were really very grateful for their
support and finally whole genome
sequencing can direct development of new
drugs and vaccines to combat human
pathogens
thorin CTC team is very very committed
to continuing the legacy we inherited
some very great bacteriologists in the
19th century so with that I'd like to
end there
I'd like slightly NCTC current team at
pictures and also the depositors and
everyone who's maintained NCTC over the
past 98 years including all of those
people that kept the records that made
this collection really valuable for
scientists in the 21st century
thank you
Thank You Julie for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button our
speakers will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question today Julie is how
long will the NCTC cultures they survive
after free drawing okay so that really
depends on the species some species we
know will survive for 50 years or more
without changing at all other species I
mentioned Helicobacter pylori in my
presentation were lost for less than
that time they might only last for five
years but we have a process in place for
checking the viability we have a lot of
historical data so we know when to make
new batches so we avoid the batches
dying we lose the culture actually you
think these are the WGS results really
represent the whole genome for all the
bacteria you've sequenced you I think it
represents most of it as I mentioned we
possibly could lose lose some of the
very small plasmids using long leap
sequencing but we can go back and use a
different technique to capture those but
in general yes I think in most cases
we've captured the whole genome Thank
You Julian what's the next project for
MCTC okay well I talked about some of
the collections that we that we store
but we haven't made available and we
have a collection of bacteriophages we
also have a collection of plasmids are
working with those at the moment and
we're going to really make those
available we want to do some sequencing
the first collection is particularly
interesting because of course with the
concerns about
the resistance looking at different
means of of treating infection bacterial
Sascha's were used quite commonly and
pill probably the 1950s when people
started using antibiotics however in the
Soviet Union and Eastern Europe they
continue to use bacteria forces because
bacteria phages of viruses that kill
bacteria making very specifically
targets individual types of bacteria so
they can be used clinically there's a
huge amount of interest in for therapy
at moment that's why we're going to be
looking at that but also plasmids can be
important in in gene transfer horizontal
gene transfer so these two connections
really our next project and that's what
we started working on right now Julie
would you like to provide any closing
remarks now I think I probably covered
most of it are really fearful to
emphasize the importance of really using
authentic cultures and in scientific
research in diagnostic testing because
without that really could be just bad
science
Julie thank you again for your
presentation and your important research
I'd also like to thank luau roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December 2018 you'll receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now and
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye bye